he vaginal microbiome
2019
where they have studied the
microbiome of
the Britain red victim and term uh
pregnant mothers
and they found that the the microfora
varies
during the pregnancy
based on the months of
pregnancy and then the variations were
seen at Family level genus level as well
as species level
and
as the figure is very difficult to do it
only by colors you can see that what are
the variations are there but in this
slide I will show you that what is the
relative abundance of
different kinds of
microphobia
overall in all the Furby cutes
is a dominant phylum
major followed by accident bacteria
and especially if you come to the
genus level
lactobacilli dominance is 77.9 as
against all others
and if this balance is maintained
usually
the humor remains healthy but if there
are disturbances uh you need to have a
remedial measures to control it
the one of the major problem in the
demand especially
related to the
microbiota is vectoral vaginosis
the most common disease and the overall
19 to 24 percent of them in reproductive
Edge has got one or the other kinds of
or more or less severe kind of
structural Genesis
in the system
and as I told earlier uh the members of
genus lactobacillus are formally
identified as Hallmark of normal healthy
vagina and they play a major role in
this
because they are accompanied with the
production of lactic acid resulting into
lowering of the original pH
and
the microfora
from the Indian studies shows that
lactobacillus rotary has been the most
dominant
species of lactobaceland within this
genus
these are some symptoms of bacterial
vaginosis and what happens the side
effects and things especially
preterm labor and delivery and post
cesarean
endometristis or post abortion pelvic
include disease or cervicitis
so these are the complications which are
result which are coming as a result of
the disturb Torah or in the original
pair or especially the vectoral vaginal
system and that is why it has got a hard
huge significance in the women's and
babies health
for treatment of bb
uh
either oral group
or interpersonal root can be employed
and most of the treatments have been
based on the individual studies done as
well as some individual studies done
especially in animal models as well as
in the human clinical tracts however the
number of human clinical trials are very
very very very less
but still such preparations are
available in the market in a very huge
diversity and quantities now probably
many of them are not really backed by
the real cleaner drugs